what makes that hood so great as these  conviction this is the only solution  he's seen it firsthand on his planet  Titan was like most planets when we  faced extinction I offered a solution  genocide where I predict independence  congratulations you're a prophet under  survivor  Tony knows just by the way that Bruce  Banner describes danos it's a different  game now  he said low-key detect on New York  that's him  he is the biggest army in the universe  and he is not gonna stop  just as shear force is something that  none of the Avengers has ever  encountered before Ferris has been  inside my head for six years so I say we  take the fight to him  heroes are only as good as their villain  but the Avengers were built for anything  for stopping Santos from completing his  goal  [Music]  on really isn't something one considers  the balancing the universe but this does  put a smile on my face  you